[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بالتزامن مع ما كشفته شبكه اي بي سي
الامريكيه من ان البنتاجون امر بسحب حامله
الطائرات يو اس اس 4 من شرق المتوسط وغداه
قرار اسرائيلي بسحب خمسه الويه قتاليه من
قطاع غزه وما تبع ذلك من تساؤلات بشان
تاثير هذه الخطوه على سير الحرب التي
تشنها على غزه نقلت صحيفه اردز عن مصدر
اسرائيلي قوله ان مرحله الحرب المقبله قد
تستمر سته اشهر وان القوات في غزه مستعده
للتوجه الى الجبهه الشماليه مع لبنان
وبشان التقييم العسكري لنتائج الحرب نقلت
صحيفه يدعو ت احرنوت عن مسؤولين في
الاجهزه الامنيه ان قدرات حماس الصاروخيه
ستبقى اقل من السابق لكنها ستستمر مع ذلك
عامين او ثلاثه واقع افادت الصحيفه بان
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه شرعت في التعامل
معه بانشاء جدران جديده وسواتر في غلاف
غزه لحمايه المركبات المدنيه من الصواريخ
المضاده للدروع رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بنيامين نتنياهو الذي يتجاهل مثل هذه
التقييمات بتاكيد ان الحرب لن تنتهي قبل
القضاء المبرم على المقاومه استبق نتائج
دراسه بداها الجيش والشباك بشان امكانيه
السماح بعوده سكان شمال ل قطاع غزه مؤكدا
خلال اجتماع لكتله حزبه في الكنيست انه لن
يسمح بمثل هذه العوده نتنياهو الذي اكد
اخيرا وبعد طول تهرب ان الحكومه هي من
ستناقش قضايا ما بعد الحرب في غزه وتبت
فيها القى في هذه القضيه بالغه الحساسيه
في احضان وزراء اليمين المتطر في حكومته
الذين كشف اثنان منهم الاكثر تشددا عن
جانب من من رؤيتهم لهذه القضيه وذلك
بدعوتهم الى تشجيع تهجير سكان قطاع غزه بل
ووصف ذلك بانه الحل الصحيح والعادل
والاخلاقي والانساني الذي تجب الاستعانه
بشركاء اسرائيل لتنفيذه موقف ربما يفسر ما
ذكرته صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه عن
خلافات جديه بشان قضيه ما بعد الحرب بين
نتنياهو والرئيس الامريكي في الفتره
الاخيره ببت بحسب ما نقلته نفس الصحيفه عن
مسؤولين امريكيين واسرائيليين باطفاء
المزيد من التوتر والحده على المحادثات
بين الرجلين خلال هذه
الفتره معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستوديو الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
اللواء فايز الدويري من الناصره الدكتور
مهند مصطفى الخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي
ومن لندن الدكتور لقاء مكي الباحث الاول
بمركز الجزيره للدراسات اهلا بهم جميعا
لواء فايز الدويري
واضح ان هناك كثير من التناقضات في النظره
الاسرائيليه لشمال غزه يعودون الاهالي لا
يعودون يعني القصه غير واضحه بالمره يعني
بالامس كان الحديث يتركز حول امكانيه
العوده وبناء مخيمات وكانت التقديرات من
حيث الاطار الزمني ان الانقاذ تحتاج لمده
عامين وان اعاده البناء الى عشره اعوام و
في هذا اليوم لا عوده
هذا هذا حديث يدور بينهم لكن هو منفصل عن
الواقع الحديث الاخر الاشد تطرفا كما ذكرت
واشار التقرير بانه يتحدث عن فتح الباب
للهجره ووضعها تحت معادله انسانيه السؤال
المطروح هل يفهموا م الوطن
ومدلولاته ليعود سموتريش الى
اوكرانيا وليعود بن كفير الى العراق لانه
جاء من هناك اذا القادم وقلت في احد
المقاب مبلات غطاء المنهل في مدينه حيفا
مكتوب عليه فلسطين
1936 اي ان غطاء المنهل اقدم من دوله
اسرائيل ب 12 عام فاذا كان غطاء الغطاء
الجارور كما يقال في اللهجه اللبنانيه
غطاء الجارور اقدم من دوله اسرائيل اذا
كان المعمرين من ابناء فلسطين عمرهم
الزمني يزيد 20 و30 عام عن عمر هذا الكيان
هذا الكيان هو اصلا كيان غاصب جاء تنفيذا
ل وعد بلفور الذي بني على اتفاقيه 19 9907
وبالتالي هذا الكيان كما جاء باراده
الاخرين سيخرج باراده ابناء الوطن ليفهموا
معنى مدلول كلمه الوطن اولا ثم يتحدثوا
اما يتحدثوا بينهم في قسم حزب الليكو
ليتحدثوا ما يقولوا الان الكلام لا ما بعد
7 اكتوبر ليس كما قبل 7 اكتوبر وا الاستاذ
محمد الم موم محمد حسنين هيكل وانت اجريت
معه حوارات مطوله له مقوله مشهوره اسرائيل
تتحمل هزيمه واحده وبعد ذلك ستكون بدايه
النهايه واعتقد ان 7 اكتوبر ستمثل تلك
الحقبه بالنسبه لك دكتور مهند عندما ياتي
نتنياهو ويقول لا عوده لسكان شمال القطاع
هل هذا هو القول الفصل والنهائي في هذا
الموضوع لا طبعا يعني نتنياهو اي يخطب
عاده ويقول تصريحات ويغيرها او يغير اهداف
الحرب كل كل مره هنالك في عدم مثابره في
التصريحات الاسرائيليه بشان قطاع غزه
بمعنى ب اخر فتره نسمع بشكل مكثف حول
موضوع التهجير وحول موضوع اعاده الاستيطان
في كطاع غزه يعني استيطان اليهود وعوده
المستوطنين الى قطاع غزه هذا الامر نحن
قلناه في السابق ولكن الان اليمين
الاسرائيلي بدا ينظر الى هذه الحرب على
انها مشروع ايديولوجي لليمين وليس جزء من
بناء واعاده بناء الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
ولذلك عندما يكون نتنياهو بعدم العوده
شمال السكان الى شمال غزه نحن لا نعلم ذلك
بمعنى انه ليس هنالك في مثابره هنالك في
حاله ارباك في الخطاب الاسرائيلي فيما
يتعلق بالحرب على قطاع غزه هذا الارباك
رايناه منذ السابع من اكتوبر وحتى هذه
اللحظه ليس هنالك في خط واضح في الاهداف
الاسرائيليه في الخطاب الاسرائيلي مؤخرا
نسمع ان اليمين يضغط نحو نحو مشروع
الترانسفير نحو مشروع تهجير الفلسطينيين
واعاده الاستيطان الى قطاع غزه وهنالك من
يحلم انه يريد ان يجلس على شاطئ بحر قطاع
غزه بدون وجود السكان الاصليين يعني مخيال
استيطاني تاريخي يع يعاد انتاجه من جديد
في داخل اليمين لكي تكون هذه الحرب مشروعا
من اجل اعاده المخيال اليميني الى قطاع
غزه هذا الامر يخيف قطاعات كبيره في داخل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي يخيف قطاعات كبيره
لانه هم يعتقدون ان هذه الحرب لم تعد من
اجل اعاده الردع او الهيبه او الكرامه او
اعاده الاصره والرهائن في قطاع غزه او
القضاء على حركه حماس اصبحت هذه الحرب
تهدف في اليمين الاسرائيلي الحاكم الان في
اسرائيل الى اعاده الاست في قطاع غزه من
خلال طرح موضوع التهجير من جديد تحدثوا
بالبدايه عن التهجير القصري بالقوه والان
يتم الحديث عن موضوع
التهجير الارادي المفارقه دكتور لقا مكي
انه في الوقت الذي يقول فيه نتنياهو ان لا
عوده لسكان شمال قطاع غزه وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يقول سنبدا قريبا عوده تدريجيه
الى غلاف غزه على مسافه من ارب الى 7 ك
مترات عن الحدود كيف تنظر الى هذه
المفارقه هو
الحقيقه هناك قانون دعائي تمارسه اسرائيل
منذ بدايتها هو يسمى قانون ل بكن او توزيع
الادوار انه كل احد من المسؤولين حتى على
مستوى السفراء والوزراء طبعا ورئيس
الوزراء يقولون شيء ليكون متوجه الى فئه
معينه يعني جال انتت رئيس وزير الدفاع هذا
ربما يستعان بكلامه من اجل ارضاء
الامريكان او الاطراف اخرى التي تعارض
التهجير ورئيس الوزراء نتنياهو كلامه او
الوزراء اليمينيين الاخرين يتحدثون
لجمهورهم الداخلي بالتالي هذا النوع نمط
من توزيع الادوار لاجل استرضاء فئات كثيره
وايضا تشتيت الانتباه وعدم التركيز على ما
تريده اسرائيل بالضبط من خلال هذه الحرب
وايضا كيلا يكن لها يعني افق محدد تحا سب
عليه انه التهجير او عدم التهجير لكن
بطبيعه الحال طبيعه الحرب وطبيعه ما يجري
في الميدان هو الذي سيحدد في النهايه ما
سيجري بشان المهجرين من اراضيهم في غزه
وبشان مستقبل القطاع بشكل عام لان عمليه
اعاده الناس الى دورهم ترتبط بطبيعه الحال
بما عمليه الاعمار وعلى الاقل اصلاح ما
يمكن اصلاحها في هذه المنطقه ناهيك عن
طبعا انتهاء الحرب وانتهاء العمليات
العسكريه وما تريد اسرائيل من امر البقاء
كقوه عسكريه محتله في شمال القطاع نعم
هناك من يزايد اللواء فايز الدويري على
نتنياهو وعلى وزير الدفاع عندما يتحدث
سموتريتش على ان وزير الماليه على انه
لابد من العوده لضمان الامن في غزه لابد
ان يعود الاستيطان الى قطاع غزه داخلها
لان هذا هو الكفيل بضمان الامن مثل ما
يحدث في الضفه الغربيه كما قال يا سيدي
يعني هل الم تكن غزه تحت الاحتلال الم تكن
مستوطنات نت سريم وجوش قطيف موجوده من
الذي اعطى امر الانسحاب شارون من الذي امر
باجبار المستوطنين على الخروج شارون من
الذي فكك المستوطنات شارون هم اصلا كانوا
موجودين وخرجوا
بسبب ضربات المقاومه علما ان ضربات
المقاومه في تلك الفتره قبل 2006 ل لم لم
يكن الحما لم تكن حماس هي حماس الحاليه
ولم تكن الجهاد هي الجهاد الحاليه الان
هؤلاء خاضوا حرب لها 85 86 يوم وهم في مع
في في حرب مستمره والجيش الاسرائيلي لم
يستطع ان يحقق ادنى مستوى من الاهداف لا
بل الان يتحدث عن بناء السواتر والجدران
في داخل الغلاف في داخل الغلاف هو سيعمل
سواتر داخل القطاع لكن هو يتحدث الان
سواتر داخل الغلاف اذا هو غير يعني ليس
لديه الثقه بان هذه المستوطنات امنه الم
تمدد اقامتهم في الفنادق بالامس الى مده
ثلاث ثلاثه شهور اخرى وستمتد الى ما بعد
ذلك لانهم هم يتحدثوا عن عمليات خاصه لمده
سته اشهر ما دامت العمليات مستمره ما
داموا مهجرين كذلك هذه العمليات لسته اشهر
تحديدا دكتور مهند مصطفى
ايه يقال انها هي الكفيله لوحدها بما سمي
عمليه تطهير مكثفه ضد الارهابيين من الذي
يضمن ان يتحقق ذلك خلال سته اشهر في ضوء
ما نشاهده يوميا من عمليات ومن
مقاومه يعني لا احد لا احد يضمن ذلك في
اسرائيل اصلا هنالك في اسرائيل يعني في شك
الان كبير جدا في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
بقدره الجيش الاسرائيلي على تحقيق اهدافه
العسكريه في قطاع غزه المجتمع الاسرائيلي
حاليا لديه ايضا عدم الثقه بالحكومه
الاسرائيليه و ببنيامين نتنياهو في قدرته
على تحقيق اهداف الحرب او الافاء بوعوده
التي كان يوعد فيها المجتمع الاسرائيلي
منذ بدايه الحرب ولذلك هذا الامر يعني غير
ممكن او غير مضمون التجربه هي في الضفه
الغربيه يعني الضفه الغربيه اسرائيل منذ
عامين تقريبا تقوم بعمليات امنيه وعسكريه
ومداهمات في الضفه الغربيه داخل المدن ال
الفلسطينيه داخل المخيمات الفلسطينيه في
الضفه الغربيه وتم تصعيد هذه المداهمات في
اخر عام وفي اخر اشهر تحديدا ولم يتم
القضاء على الحركه النضال الفلسطينيه في
الضفه الغربيه لم يتم القضاء على النزعه
النضال ولا و ولا على المقاومه في الضفه
الغربيه ولذلك اذا كان هنالك في فشل في
القضاء على النزعه النضال في الضفه
الغربيه فكيف لها ان تنجح ضمن عمليات
عينيه ايضا في قطاع غزه المجتمع صل في
تصوري يدرك ذلك في هذه المرحله بالاضافه
الى ذلك هنالك العامل السياسي الداخلي في
اسرائيل هذا العامل يتصاعد ويتفاقم اكثر
واكثر في هذه المرحله اليوم كان في قرار
للمحكمه العليا بالغاء قانون المعقوليه
هذا الامر س سيفاقم الازمه السياسيه
الداخليه في اسرائيل المتفاقم اصلا هنالك
في اليوم كان تصريح لبنك اسرائيل ان
التضخم المالي في اسرائيل سيصل الى 6% وان
ال العلاقه بين الدين وبين الناتج القومي
سيرتفع من 60% الى 80% بمعنى ان هنالك في
تراكم لازمات داخليه وهذا كل كل ذلك ولم
نتحدث عن موضوع الاسرى والرهائن وهو موضوع
ما زال مشتعلا وهنالك الان مظاهرات تطالب
باستقاله نتنياهو بمعنى ان الوضع الداخلي
في داخل اسرائيل بالاضافه الى ازمه الجبهه
الشماليه في اسرائيل كل هذه العوامل
الداخليه الان سوف تدخل كل موضوع الحرب في
قطع غزه الى مرحله جديده على المستوى
الداخلي ب معنى ان هنالك الان في عدم ثقه
بقدره للجيش وحكومه على تحقيق الوعود التي
لم يتم تحقيقها في ال 80 يوم الماضيه فكيف
يمكن تحقيقها في المرحله القادمه ونموذج
الضفه الغربيه موجود هذا النموذج العيني
والحي ما زال موجودا امام الاسرائيليين
ولذلك هنالك في شك كبير في قدره اسرائيل
على تحقيق ذلك في ظل كل هذه الاجواء
الملبد دكتور لقا مكي تقول الولايات
المتحده انها ستسحب حام الطائرات يو اس اس
جيرالد فورد من شرق المتوسط في الايام
القليله المقبله والتبرير هو حتى تتمكن من
الاستعداد لعمليات النشر المستقبليه كيف
قرات هذا هذا التحرك
الامريكي باعتقادي ان هذا التحريك او هذا
القرار هو رساله موجهه لى حكومه نتنياهو
انا اظن ان ما تسرب من امر الخلافات
العميقه بين اداره بايدن وحكومه نتنياهو
بشان مرحله ما بعد الحرب في غزه قد افضى
الى قناعه لدى اداره بايدن بان
نتنياهو يجب ان يواجه برساله شديده بان
امريكا ودعم امريكا لن يستمر الى الابد
اذا لم ينصاع الاسرائيليون الى الاراده
الامريكيه بشان المقاربه ما بعد الحرب
اعتقد ان سحب الاسطول او حامله الطائرات
والسفن التي ترافقها وهي جميعها سفن
هجوميه هي رساله الى حكومه نتنياهو بان
الدعم الامريكي يمكن ان يتقلص بان هذه
السفن التي كانت تمثل قوه ردع امريكيه
لصالح اسرائيل سواء ضد حماس او ضد اي قوه
اخرى يمكن ان تهاجم اسرائيل لم تعد موجوده
ولن تعود موجوده وان امريكا والدعم
الامريكي يمكن ان يتقلص تدريجيا ان لم
تستجب حكومه نتنياهو ل الاراده الامريكيه
نحن نعرف ان اسرائيل تدرك جيدا انها بدون
الدعم الامريكي لا يمكن ان تستمر في الحرب
لبضعه ايام وبالتالي اعتقد ان نتنياهو يجب
ان يفهم ذلك بشكل مباشر وهذه المره بطريقه
عمليه وليس فقط من خلال محاوله الاقناع
بالكلام انا اقرا سحب هذه السفن او هذا
الاسطول الضخم او القوه الناريه الضخمه من
هذه الزاويه وليس لاي زاويه اخرى لانه من
الناحيه العمليات امريكا ليس هناك ما
يدعوها الى السحب لانه لم يتغير شيء في
الواقع ما زالت التهديدات قائمه ما زالت
الحرب الاقليميه ممكنه لا سما مع حزب الله
في الشمال وبالتالي سحب هذه السفن سحب هذه
القوه الناريه من الشرق المتوسط بدون تغير
المعطيات الميدانيه هو اعتقد انه موجه
تهديدا بسبب الخلاف العلني الذي اصبح
علنيا بين تلبيب وواشنطن ولكن هل يمكن
اللواء فايز الدويري ان ان تلتقط الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ذلك لان الخلاف يبدو بالاساس
كان حول ما يسمى اليوم التالي حول سقوط
المدنيين حول دخول المساعدات وغير ذلك
الان ما يقال عن اليوم التالي تبحث لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه تبحث مجلس الحرب الان
نتنياهو قال بان الحكومه هي التي ستصبح
تبت في هذا الموضوع اذا حسم الامر في هذه
الاجواء كف كيف يمكن ل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ان تلتقط هذه الرساله التي
اشار اليها الدكتور لقا مك يعني هذه بحاجه
الى تعزيز وتوضيح اكبر هذه مجموعه جيرالد
فورد هي تتحرك بصوره دوريه من مكان الى
اخر وهناك برامج مد سلفا سواء تاتي الى
الشرق الاوسط بناء على التطورات اذا ما
حدث امر طارق ستتوجه الى بحر الصين
الجنوبي اذا هي هذه قوه متحركه ترسل
حركتها هي بناء على تغيرات في الظروف
وارسال رسائل هادفه اذا الهدف الاول اتفق
مع الدكتور فيما ذكره لكن حتى تكون تلتقط
اسرائيل الرساله بوضوح هناك امور اعتبرها
يعني قد تبدو اقل اهميه ولكنها اكثر
دلاله الان لا يزال التعاون
العسكري في في قمه المستوى
وعمليات الموافقه نعم لم يكن هناك موافقه
على طائرات الاباتشي لكن كان هناك موافقه
على ما هو اهم من طائرات الاباتشي تزويد
بذخيره المدفعيه التي هي وقود الحرب اذا
ارادت امريكا ان ترس رساله واضحه عليها ان
تشعر اي الكيان بان تقديم المساعدات
العسكريه الضروريه الملحه الانيه هي ذات
التاثير المباشر ولكن لا اتوقع الامريكين
سيلج لذلك على الاقل لو يلغوا تفعيل قانون
طوارئ الذي يجيز تقديمها من خارج الكونغرس
نعم اذا كانت بعض الضغوط الامريكيه دكتور
مهند مصطفى استقبلها البعض ببعض التذمر
بالحكومه بالحديث عن الاجانب وضروره عدم
ترك القرار مرهون بالاجانب
وزير العلوم الاسرائيلي اوفير اوكوس ايه
اشار ب بشكل واضح قال يجب علينا ان نتجنب
الانحنا بالضبط هذا هو تعبيره الانحناء
للضغوط الامريكيه لانه لن يساعد في تحقيق
اهداف الحرب وقال يجب ان ان ان نشكل اجماع
واسع على ان حل الدولتين هذا لم يعد
موجودا بالمره بمعنى رفع سقف الخلاف مع
الولايات المتحده الى اخره هل يمكن ان
يكون لامثال هؤلاء القول الفصل في في
تحديد الموقف الرسمي
الاسرائيلي لا وفي ا كونس وغيره من
الوزراء اليمنيين هذول يعني يحملون خطابا
شعبويا يخاطب قواعد اليمين الغوغائيين في
اسرائيل ولكن يجب ان ندرك امرا واحدا هذا
ما تدرك المؤسسه الرسميه الاسرائيليه
الدوله العميقه المؤسسه العسكريه
الاستخباراتيه
الامنيه الامن القومي الاسرائيلي مرتكز
على قواعد متعدده اهم قاعده في الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي هو الاعتماد على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نتنياهو نفسه
يفهم ذلك يدرك ذلك الجيش يفهم ذلك ولذلك
كل الحديث عن انه على اسرائيل ان تكون
مستقله عن الدعم الامريكي ان تكون مستقله
عن عن الدعم الامريكي على المستوى الدولي
ليس فقط على المستوى العسكري على المستوى
الدولي على المستوى الدبلوماسي هذا الامر
غير ممكن اسرائيل لا تستطيع ان تكون دوله
قويه لديها قوه ردع بدون وجود الدعم
الامريكي وما حدث في الساب من اكتوبر اكد
ذلك منظومه الارن القومي الاسرائيلي لا
يمكن ان تكوم بدون الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولذلك كل هذه الخطابات هي
خطابات
جاءت فقط من اجل ارضاء الشارع اليميني
المؤسسه العسكريه الامنيه المساد
الاسرائيلي جهاز المخابرات الاسرائيليه
الدوله العميقه وحتى اقطاب مهمه في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه مثل بيني جانس يوف
جالانت جادي ايزنكوت هؤلاء الاقطاب هم
الذين بالنهايه يحددون السياسه الامنيه
والعسكريه لاسرائيل وهذه السياسه الامنيه
والعسكريه لا يمكن ان تكون في اسرائيل
بدون وجود الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ولذلك الكثير من وزراء ين يتحدثون انه يجب
التحرر والاستقلال من الدعم الامريكي ولكن
في ظل الازمه وفي ظل وجود اسرائيل في ازمه
الوح الدوله الوحيده التي تدعم وتثابر في
دعمها العسكري والدبلوماسي والسياسي
لاسرائيل هي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ولذلك بالنهايه التوجه الاستراتيجي
الاسرائيلي سيكون بالنهايه هو الانصياع
الى الضغط الامريكي قد يكون هنالك في
مقاومه من نتنياهو لهذا الانصياع اذا اذا
مس مصالحه الشخصيه و لكن في النهايه
نتنياهو يدرك انه انه لا يستطيع ان يواجه
الضغط الامريكي او الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
اذا ارادت ان تفرض نفسها على اسرائيل يعني
اذا امريكا ارادت ان تفرض نفسها
واستراتيجيتها على اسرائيل هي تستطيع فعل
ذلك المؤسسه العسكريه سوف تقف مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ضد اسرائيل انا فقط
اريد ان ان اذكر انه عندما قرر نتنياهو
قصف المفاعل النووي الايراني عندما كان
ايهود براك وزير الدفاع رئيس المساد في
ذلك الحين مير دغان توجه الى البيت الابيض
واخبرهم ان اسرائيل تريد قصف المفاعل
النووي الايراني وامريكا منعت ذلك
بالنهايه هنالك في دوله عميقه فيما يتعلق
بالامن القومي الاسرائيلي الامن
الاستراتيجي ليس وزراء مثل مثل ا كونيس
وبين كفير وسموت هم من يحددون هذه
الاستراتيجيه من يحددها هي الدوله العميقه
في اسرائيل الاستراتيجيه التي تحددها
المؤسسه العسكريه والموساد والاجهزه
الامنيه ورجالات الدوله المهمين مثل بيني
جانس ايزين كود رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي
هرسي هاليفي وامثال جلنت نعم هو هو ربما
كلامك هذا دكتور مهند هو الذي جعل لبيد
زعيم المعارضه دكتور لقاء مكي يكون
متفائلا عندما يقول العام المقبل سيكون
عاما مختلفا لان الجماعات المتطرفه سترحل
نتنياهو سيذهب الى بيته وسنبدا من جديد هل
هذه البدايه الجديده تبدو لك
وشيكه لا
اولا لان حرب غزه حتى الان لم تفصح عن كل
اسرارها رغم مرور حوالي ثلاثه اشهر من
القتال والقتل العنيف لكن اولا المقاومه
ما زالت قائمه وبقوه واسرائيل لم تحقق
اهدافها ولا اي من اهداف حقيقه سوى
التدمير والتدمير لم يكن اصلا معلنا رغم
انه موجود في داخل العقليه والعقيده
الصهيونيه وما زال هناك مازال والان يواجه
نتنياهو كما اشار الاساتذه الافاضل مشكله
عميقه في في داخل اسرائيل واليمين ايضا
وبالتالي جزء كبير من هذا الخطاب موجه
للداخل في محاوله الاسترضاء هذا الخلافات
الداخليه والخلاف بين واشنطن وتل ابيب
وعدم تحقيق النتائج حقيقيه على الارض وسحب
خمس الويه قبل ان يتحقق اي شيء في الداخل
واقتراب من المرحله الثالثه من من الحرب
كل هذا يؤشر ان الحرب ستكون فعلا طويله
ولكن ليس بالضروره لمصلحه اسرائيل اعتقد
ان هو يريد تمديد الحرب اطول فتره ممكنه
حتى الانتخابات الامريكيه هو يريد توريط
بايدن بظل بالاستمرار بدعم اسرائيل لانه
لا يستطيع بايدن التخلي عن دعم اسرائيل
مطلقا هذه عقيده امريكيه مباشره بغض النظر
عن ماهيه الرئيس وهويه
الرئيس الان يريد نتنياهو الوصول الى
الرئيس المقبل وقد يكون ترامب ترامب هو
الرجل المفضل لد نتنياهو الذي سينقذه من
من السجن ينقذه من الذهاب الى بيته الامر
يتعلق بصراع داخلي بين المعارضه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه وبين اليمين وبالتالي
اظن انه جزء كبير من فشل اسرائيل في هذه
الحرب يتعلق بعدم ترتيب البيت الداخلي
بالصراعات الداخليه اسرائيل ليست متفقه
ليست على قلب رجل واحد وسيستمرون كذلك
والهزيمه الهزيمه امام المقاومه حقيقه
عمقت بالشرخ الداخلي الاسرائيلي وزادت في
حجم الارتباك وجعلت الان الهزيمه يبحثون
عن كبش فداء للهزيمه نتنياهو طبعا الشخصيه
المفضله لكي يكون كبش فداء واظن ان
التداعيات الصراع بين واشنطن وتل ابيب
ستستمر لا سيما يعني قبل بدء الحمله
الانتخابيه في فبراير المقبل في واش في
الولايات المتحده وعندما تكون الاجواء
ملبده ومعقده بمثل هذا الشكل اللواء فايز
الدويري من انعكاس كل ذلك على الواقع
الميداني في في غزه على العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في غزه كما تسميه
يعني هذه مجموعه العوامل التي تطرق لها
وتحدث فيها الاخوه يضاف لها
حقيقه او قناعات حقيقيه ترست خت وتجذرت
لدى صانع القرار خاصه في المستوى العسكري
والامني بان جيش الاحتلال بذل اقصى ما
يمكن من اجل تحقيق الاهداف ولم ولم ينجح
بالامر الاخر ان القدرات القتاليه له
للاستمرار بهذا المستوى من الحرب لا
يستطيع ان ان يفعل ذلك لاكثر من اسابيع
معدوده اذا عليه ان يتحول الى مقاربه اخرى
تنهي مصطلح الحرب وتذهب باتجاه ما يطلق
عليها عمليات المناوره وكان توضيحا واضحا
لانها الكلفته الماديه اقل كلفته من حيث
الخساره البشريه اقل اي تجسر الفجوه جزئيه
مع امريكا فستكون كانها طوق نجاه ل
للمعتدين على الاقل ان كانوا موجودين
وعسكريين اذا الان التوجه الى المرحله
الثالثه والاسراع في الدخول في المرحله
الثالثه لانه في شمال القطاع دخلت فعليا
بالمرحله الثالثه من خلال ما جرى هذا
اليوم في ال 24 ساعه الاخيره وتحتاج الى
اسبوع الى 10 ايام ستدخل الزاما كما ارى
وبالتالي الان ن نعود نتحدث عن وضع عسكري
عملياتي مختلف كليا قد يمتد سست اشهر او
اكثر ننهي معك دكتور مهند مصطفى قبل قليل
اشرت الى قرار المحكمه العليا بابطال ما
يسمى قانون المعقوليه وهو قدره المحكمه
العليا على ابطال بعض قرارات الحكومه
البعض في اسرائيل من غلاه اليمين طبعا
اعتبروا هذا مضرا بالمجهود الحربي كما
سموه هل فعلا سيكون
كذلك لا هذا الغاء الق قانون سيكون مضرا
في الوحده السياسيه في اسرائيل سوف يزيد
الطين بلا في داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
علينا ان نذكر هذه اول مره في تاريخ دوله
اسرائيل المحكمه العليا تلغي قانون اساس
هذا الامر غير مسبوق في اسرائيل هذا الامر
سيؤدي الى زياده الانقسام السياسي في داخل
اسرائيل وفي داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه وقد
يؤدي قد يؤدي استاذ محمد الى بدايه خروج
جانس من الحكومه لانه اليمين الان سيبدا
حمله تحريض على المحكمه العليا جانس لن
يتحمل ذلك جمهوره لن يتحمل ذلك وسوف يضغط
عليه للخروج من هذه الحكومه ولذلك الغاء
هذا القانون من قبل المحكمه العليا
والالغاء جاء ثمانيه مقابل سبعه بمعنى ان
هناك ايضا انقسام في داخل المحكمه العليا
الالغاء لم يكن عليه اجماع في داخل
المحكمه العليا هذا الامر هذا الانقسام في
المحكمه العليا سوف ينعكس على الانقسام في
الشارع الاسرائيلي سوف ينعكس على الانقسام
في داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه وتدفع جانس
للخروج من الحكومه وبدء مرحله جديده
سياسيه في اسرائيل تطالب باقاله نتنياهو
والذهاب الى انتخابات هذا الامر لا شك انه
سيؤدي تاثير على الحرب بمعنى ان غياب
الوحده الداخليه الصراعات السياسيه
الداخليه الغير مسبوقه باي تاريخ في
اسرائيل خلال الحرب هذا امر غير مسبوق في
يعني في في تاريخ اسرائيل هذا هذا
الانقسام الداخلي لا شك انه سيف يؤثر على
الحرب في قطاع غزه شكرا لك دكتور مهند
مصطفى من الناصره شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
لقاء مكي من لندن وشكرا لضيفنا هنا في
الاستديو اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي بهذا نصل الى نهايه
حلقه اليوم موعدنا يتجدد غدا باذن الله في
تمام الثامنه ونص بتوقيت مكه المكرمه